frau schneider
wenn dir das wie geht es ihnen gut drei
tage in qigong ein film der deutsch
französisch iranischen regisseurin emily
atef erzählt die geschichte eines
interviews dass romy schneider im märz
mit 81 mit zwei sternen journalisten
geführt hat das interview fand in einem
kurhotel an der französischen
atlantikküste statt wenn das sich romy
schneider zurückgezogen hatte um sich
von einem tiefpunkt ihres lebens zu
erholen
ihre beziehung mit dem franzosen daniel
biasini war in die brüche gegangen
ihr ehemann harry meyer hatte sich vor
einigen jahren hängt mit ihrem sohn
david warum ich schneider in einem
unruhigen der entfremdung sich nähernden
verhältnis einer der beiden stern
journalisten ist der fotograf robert
lebeck der damals in qigong am atlantik
bewegende sehr intime sehr sprechende
fotos der deutschen schauspielerin
gemacht hat
der andere michael jürgs stellt ihr
fragen die von heute aus betrachtet
etwas über griffiges haben aber damals
von romy schneider offenbar als
selbstverständliche abrechnung mit ihrem
leben akzeptiert romy schneider wird von
marie bäumer gespielt und marie bäumer
ist bereits vor dem kinostart von drei
tage in die bohrung für ihren auftritt
sehr gelobt worden und ganz zu recht
gibt sich völlig hin dieser rolle sie
spielt romy schneider als würde sie in
romy schneiders haut griechen wollen sie
ersetzt romy schneider geradezu
zumindest was die äußeren züge angeht
das war's romy schneider wirklich war
kann man in ihren filmen sehen das was
die figur um mich schneider für uns
heute noch bedeutet und rätsel
eine tragische gestalt ein trauriges
schicksal das kann man auch für diesen
film sieht
ein film der mit zwei stunden lang wirkt
der sich auf der schönheit an der
schwarz weißen bilder etwas zu sehr aus
wut und der um es offen zu sagen auch
etwas zu gemächlich etwas zu langsam mit
der geschichte umgeht
die erzählen möchte ein film der nicht
zuspitzt der eher entspannt ein film der
die konflikte wieder aufhebt dir
aufreißt und er am ende auch der figur
der freundin die von birgit minichmayr
sehr virtuos verkörpert wird nicht den
großen auftritt die große kritik die
große abrechnung mit dem journalismus
könnt die in dieser figur angelegt sind
ein film also der mit zehn nominierungen
in diesem jahr für den deutschen
filmpreis sehr gut bedient ist der gut
aussieht der wie manche deutschen filme
etwas an griffigkeit etwas an drama und
an stringenz der geschichte vermissen
lässt und der insofern auch typisch für
das deutsche kino ist das nach mehr als
30 jahren auf seine große internationale
traurige star schauspielerin romy
schneider zurückblickt
und gegen ihre arbeit oder frau
schneider
ich wusste nicht dass hier ein interview
mit mir führen wollen